[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Avengers infinity saga
Marvel rewatch video there were all
kinds of Marvel phase 4 big Easter eggs
setting up Avengers endgame in the
Marvel phase for movies that we didn't
spot the first time we saw the movie so
we'll break everything down we're also
doing the Infinity saga box set giveaway
for all the movies also be naming a
winner during this video for the first
box set I've got two to give away all
you have to do to enter that is just be
a subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the Avengers movie on the
video careful for spoilers for all the
Marvel movies so far and I'll just
number these as we go along just because
there are so many Easter eggs starting
at the beginning the movie literally
starts with a title sequence revealing
itself inside the tesseract framing what
the entire Infinity saga of movies is
going to be about the Infinity stones
themselves at the time there were a lot
of fan theories that the space stone was
inside the tesseract but that wasn't
confirmed by Marvel till years later for
those that remember the epic Thanos
named theory of the stones the voiceover
during that scene might sound like a
evil version of Benedict Cumberbatch
doing a Doctor Strange voice but the
character is actually named the other he
Stannis's servant who also comes back to
be killed by Ronan during guardians of
the galaxy he's played by Alexei Denisov
from the Whedon verse there are lot of
other Whedon verse alumni that appeared
during the Avengers and other Marvel
movies throughout the MCU
the character of the other is the one
who serves as the go-between for Loki
and Thanos and sanctuary where Loki
seeks an alliance with him as a path to
revenge on earth so when they bigger
later in the movie and Loki shows up
looking like he's half dead at the
beginning of the film it's the other who
tortured him into submission for Thanos
Thanos doesn't actually touch Loki
himself for the first time until
Avengers infinity war when he touches
him to kill him and as you notice here
Theo says rocket chair is also very
different looking from the one we saw in
guardians the actor who plays Thanos is
also a very different person in his
visual design is very different the
reason his character model looks so
different is because they hadn't cast
Josh Brolin to actually speak lines of
dialogue as Stannis yet and this is a
very early template for what Fanus would
become damian Portier is the person
playing him here he's actually talked
about it later he said it was a pretty
cool experience for him but they
didn't bring him back to do more Santos
later he just got to play Thanos on
screen very briefly for this Avengers
post-credit scene we get our first look
at the scepter
they clearly imply that Loki knows
there's an infinity stone inside and
that's where its power comes from there
were a lot of fan theories about the
mind stone early on but it wasn't till
years later in Avengers age of Ultron
that they confirmed that they show the
[ __ ] our efore the first time we see
project Pegasus for the first time which
we later learn was originally created by
Howard Stark in partnership with shield
and Marvel of the Kree to study the
tesseract trying to explore its
potential for unlimited clean energy and
faster than light travel we also learn a
lot of modern-day tech like Iron Man's
arc reactors were inspired by the
tesseract as the space stone infinity
stone energy in a lot of shields modern
day tech like the cloaking shields for
the helicarriers the weaponry is also
based on alien Kree and Skrulls tech
from the 90s you also have to keep in
mind that Nick Fury's sword Space
Station is also based on Marvel's
original ship which was in orbit in the
90s cloaked from Earth censors so a
couple minutes later in the film when
they blow the base up Nick Fury isn't
that upset because he's already busy
building a giant space station in orbit
right now he has his backup site we meet
Black Widow and the new Mark Ruffalo
Hulk for the first time everything from
Incredible Hulk is still candid to the
MCU even though it's a different actor
the reason why Edward Norton said he
parted ways with Marvel before the
Avengers movie was because he said that
he wanted to do a darker version of the
Hulk than Marvel had planned for the
character they'd originally planned to
do a solo hulk trilogy with him I
discussed the plot of what that trilogy
would have been during my Incredible
Hulk infinity saga video so I'll add a
link for that in the description below
but the final scene of Edward Norton
opening his eyes after meditating with
the green eyes was meant to be a setup
for the famous Hulk line that's my
secret I'm always angry in that now he
can actually control when he becomes the
Hulk when he jokes about swallowing the
tesseract that's exactly what goose does
back in the 90s then throws it up like
some kind of cosmic hairball at the end
of the Captain Marvel movie you also
notice that outside to all the agents
waiting for the Hulk are holding those
phase two weapons powered by tesseract
energy when Nick Fury meets the shield
Oversight Committee we see Gideon Malick
for the first time
Marvel phase 2 setup he was later
revealed to be the head of hydras
operations in America during agents of
shield they actually just introduced his
grandfather on that show right before
the events of the Captain America First
Avenger movie they referenced phase 2
now in the movie it's all about the
weaponry that they're developing but
this is also Marvel's clever way of
getting fans hyped up about the Marvel
phase 2 of movies in real life when Nick
Fury goes to recruit Captain America for
the Avengers he hands a file on the
tesseract it mentions Mephisto by name
and the infinity gems curly we're all
hoping to see Mephisto appear in one of
the upcoming Marvel phase 4 movies or
Disney Plus series like Doctor Strange 2
or 1 division later Marvel would wreak
on some of this document and start
calling the infinity gems the Infinity
stones and stop mentioning Mephisto
mostly I think because of rights issues
with Fox because at the time they plan
to do a more comic book accurate version
of the Infinity Gauntlet saga storyline
matisse toe is just a big part of that
with Thanos if you've never read the
comic book so originally it sounded like
they had big plans for the Mephisto
character in the Infinity saga but then
had to change that later we see the
stark tower for the first time which
would later become the Avengers tower
and while everyone is still wondering
who bought the tower during spider-man
far from home a lot of people are hoping
it's Norman Osborn and Oscorp for
possible MCU Green Goblin or even the
new Fantastic Four's Baxter building
when Marvel was making the first
Avengers movie they actually got
approval to add the Oscorp building to
the New York City skylines so you would
have seen Oscorp right here near the
Avengers tower but the reason why it's
not in the movie is because they didn't
get the approval till after the visual
effects were done for this scene so they
didn't have time to add it back in Tony
and peppers joke about 12 percent credit
strangely gets used again during
guardians of the galaxy's 12% of a
planned joke that's probably just a
coincidence though but they talk about
their relationship foreshadowing their
eventual daughter wearing the Iron Man
armor that he built for pepper implying
her future in the armor as an adult
impossible return in the future Disney
Plus series there was also a very big
Avengers endgame deleted scene in
alternate ending with Iron Man inside
the soul world of the soul gem speaking
to adult Morgan Stark played by
Katherine Langford from 13 reasons why
Colson breaks in they joke about iron
man's life model decoy currently on
agents of shield Colson is actually a
real life model decoy with the memories
of the original Colson who died bringing
this joke around a full circle they also
referenced Coulson's girlfriend the
cellist they did her as a character on
agents of shield she was played by
another fellow Whedon vers alumni amy
acker
he shows Iron Man a bunch of footage
from the other Marvel phase 1 movies
including Incredible Hulk Captain
America First Avenger and Thor Coulson
also sets up The Wizard of Oz Captain
America joke with him not getting any
pop-culture references because he was in
the ice later during Winter Soldier they
actually show him riding down a list of
pop-culture stuff that he needs to catch
up on the reason why he understood the
reference for Wizard of Oz though is
because that movie came out of 1939 long
before he became Captain America Chris
Evans also explained that by the time we
get to Avengers age of Ultron Captain
America is fully caught up on pop
culture history thanks to the internet
internet so helpful iron man makes his
Thor Point Break joke which they brought
back in Thor Ragnarok Point Break the
Helicarrier design itself here in the
bridge is actually meant to mimic the
shield logo in as cool as that is later
we learned that Hydra had so deeply
penetrated all aspects of shield that
had they not destroyed this Helicarrier
during the movie Hydra probably would
have remotely taken control of it during
Winter Soldier like they did with that
other new helicarriers with Zola's
algorithm speaking of hail Hydra
Sitwell is sitting at the console near
Captain America and Coulson they have a
big world war two call back when a
survivor stands up to Loki who demands
that they kneel before him and then
later Thor tells Loki that the throne
would ill suit him they paid that joke
off during Thor Ragnarok when it was
revealed that Loki had let the nine
realms fall into chaos while pretending
to be Odin because he spent most of his
time goofing off creating plays about
himself
Oshin you also notice that Odin's Ravens
are flying around them during this scene
- they're not real ravens they're more
like advanced Asgardian magical
creatures that do surveillance for Odin
they have that funny line from Captain
America about God not dressing like Thor
and Loki there is an actual God in the
Marvel Universe he's called the one
above all but who knows if we'll ever
see him in an MCU project they have
their very iconic fight scene where we
find out that Iron Man's newer infinity
stone base arc reactor is actually
boosted by Thor's magical lightning
later they brought this back around
during Avengers endgame when Iron Man
planned ahead and built a special
receptacle into his new nano armor to
collect even more energy giving him an
even bigger boost the answer the age-old
question what would happen if Thor's
hammer hit Captain America shield
creates a massive shock wave they also
brought this back during the exact same
endgame fight when cap throws the hammer
at his shield by himself bouncing it off
to hit fan OHS with even more force
Iron Man starts wearing his Black
Sabbath the shirt is a reference to the
I am Iron Man song from the end of the
first Iron Man movie they introduced
that funny Galaga man scene then brought
him back five seconds later to pay the
joke off we get our first real big Hulk
Iron Man scene setting up the science
Bros pairing and setting up a huge
Avengers end game Infinity Gauntlet
twist when iron man tells banner that
maybe the Hulk maybe he became the Hulk
to save himself during the initial gamma
accident as if the Hulk saved him then
they joke I guess we'll find out if this
was all for reason if he became the Hulk
for a reason turns out that reason is
because the Infinity Gauntlet gives off
enormous amounts of gamma energy as he
later says it's kind of like I was made
for this
Captain America finds all that phase 2
weapon prototypes with Hydra logos on
them they're literally confiscated red
skull weapons from World War two so
shield is not being subtle about this
and it's all in service of the eventual
Winter Soldier hail Hydra twist during
Marvel phase two phase two weapons
phase two Hydra take over plot also see
what they did there we get our Loki
black widow scene where Loki basically
tells us part of the plot of the Black
Widow movie during Marvel phase 4 that
movies set during the past but he
references all the red on her ledger all
the bodies she dropped when she was a
black widow when he calls her Drake offs
daughter Drake off is actually the
in general in the Black Widow trailer
who's leading the Red Room program he's
also the person who found Natasha is an
orphan and brought her into the program
so even though he's not her biological
father like Red Skull reveals during
Avengers endgame Drake off is her
adoptive father her real father we would
learn is actually named Ivan and that's
them doing a version of her comic book
backstory where she did have a
biological family but most of them died
in a fire she survived on the streets
until she was taken in by another Soviet
soldier and then given to the Red Room
program when she was old enough we have
our first classic Iron Man Captain
America standoff this tension was only
heightened by the presence of the mine
stone there was always this going on
between the two of them which would boil
over during Civil War
Captain America also tells Iron Man that
he's not the man to make the sacrifice
play here which sets up his sacrifice
wielding the Nano Infinity Gauntlet in
Avengers endgame dying in the process
when the Hulk talks about putting a
bullet in his mouth and the Hulk
spitting it out that's a deleted scene
from The Incredible Hulk movie they took
it out just because it was too dark but
it was also at the same time we saw
Captain America in the MCU setting him
up because his movie came out right
after the Incredible Hulk when banner
finally hooks out there's a funny
message nearby on the bulkhead this is
warning contents under pressure he tries
and fails to pick up Thor's hammer
something that they brought back during
Avengers age of Ultron when almost all
the Avengers try to pick it up the
Russos also revealed that Captain
America was always worthy so it's him
here pretending like he can't pick it up
just a spare Thor the heart attack that
he's having in the background watching
this as his eyes go wide
Loki kills Coulson but not after he gets
him with a couple of sick burns and the
destroyer gun that was designed based on
the schematics shield took from the
destroyer after the Thor movie right
after this Joss Whedon would bring
Coulson back during agents of shield
through project Tahiti which they
explained was Nick Fury's back-up plan
for resurrecting dead Avengers should
they ever truly die but for those of you
wondering about Black Widow coming back
after Avengers endgame what about
project Tahiti they explained that that
was just a TV show thing it's not
something that they're gonna do in the
movies at any point most of you probably
recognize Harry Dean Stanton from one of
his many movies in his cameo scene here
when Ironman faces off against Loki and
Don's the mark 7 armor you notice in the
background of this scene at the bar
there's a picture of him and pepper
was taken during Ironman - at the races
Ironman quotes The Avengers comic book
catchphrase
Earth's Mightiest Heroes and even though
they have their big Avengers Assemble
moment and recite a bunch of comic book
catchphrases they wouldn't let anybody
in any of the movies say Avengers
Assemble until Captain America in
Avengers end game when Ironman tells
Loki there's no version of this where he
comes out on top
Loki actually does wind up escaping on
top of things with the tesseract during
Avengers end game that's the Loki that
will follow in present day during the
events of the Loki Disney Plus series
with the time variants authority who are
kind of like the time cops of the MCU as
a lot of people suspected the reason why
Loki's mine Stone doesn't work on Iron
Man here is because his arc reactor is
based on Infinity stone technology
counteracting the cosmic energy of the
mine stone we get our big Black Widow
Hawkeye Budapest reference that's also
something we're going to see during
Marvel phase 4 in the Black Widow movie
this place at the beginning of the Black
Widow trailer is literally Budapest
where she comes to look for yelling at
Bulova but we get a cameo scene from
another Whedon verse alumni Ashley
Johnson she also got a longer deleted
scene earlier in the movie at her cafe
near the Avengers tower with Captain
America which also winds up being
another Stan Lee cameo scene Captain
America is drawing the Avengers tower he
was a sketch artist before he became
Captain America so even with all of his
new powers he still knows how to draw
really well Iron Man even has one of his
sketches from World War 2 the monkey
that he draws here sitting on his desk
during Captain America Civil War during
their big Avengers Assemble moment cap
recites Holt's signature catchphrase
Hulk smash setting him loose later when
he thrashes Loki they actually brought
that joke back during Thor Ragnarok and
Avengers endgame to show the aftermath
of this scene where they all come for
him after Ironman takes out the [ __ ] our
ship he also lands right next to the
swarm a place that gives him the idea
for the post-credits scene you know
there's a shawarma place that I wanted
to try out when Ironman takes the nuke
through the portal to destroy Thanos as
fleet this is actually how fan O's
learned who he was then mentions him by
name during their fight in Avengers
infinity war on Titan there's also the
same music cue when the portal is
closing making it seem like Ironman is
gonna die and not make it back they
played that exact same music cue right
before Ironman snaps the Nano Infinity
Gauntlet in
Avengers endgame right when everyone
thinks that all is lost during this
ending scene with all the big montages
in the news broadcast we get another
Stan Lee cameo scene he's playing chess
in the park it's actually the same place
in the same park from x-men The Last
Stand where magneto is playing chess
originally Kevin Feige actually tried to
include a young version of magneto in
Captain America First Avenger he was
going to be one of the kids that were
rounded up and put into red skulls camps
but Fox wouldn't approve the use of the
character at the time you notice the
a113 reference up in the corner here -
that's a reference to the famous Cal
arts a113 classroom that the founders of
Pixar always sneak into their movies
they reveal the plans for the new
Avengers Tower currently owned by new
management we'll probably find out
exactly who during spider-man 3 next
year the logos for each of the Avengers
are also meant to be their separate
rooms the labs the facilities designed
for each of their powers the
post-credits scene is obviously the big
fan of reveal the line to court death is
a reference to the Infinity Gauntlet
comic book storyline where Thanos is
literally courting death romantically by
snapping half of all life from the
universe with the Infinity Gauntlet the
closest we've gotten to the physical
embodiment of death in the MCU is
actually the hella character because
she's the goddess of death but she's not
meant to be this version of death then
the final post-credit scene is the
shawarma scene the story behind this is
also very funny - they literally filmed
this post-credit scene the night before
the movie premiered in theaters
literally the night before the reason
why Chris Evans doesn't speak and just
holds his hand up to his face is because
he had to grow a beard for another movie
and they covered his jawline with a
really bad prosthetic but if you spotted
any other big Marvel phase 4 Easter eggs
or other big Avengers end games set up
moments that I didn't mention during the
video just write them below in the
comments so congratulations to the
giveaway winner for the first Infinity
Saga box set a Baez please email me on
the about page my channel so I can get
your contact details everyone leave your
requests for other Marvel bonus videos
in the comments below - so everyone
click here for my new spider-man 3 video
and click here for all my Marvel
infinity saga re-watch Easter Egg videos
thank you so much for watching everyone
stays safe I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]